hi everyone and welcome to our last
session of the day I'm Julie pearl and
I've been at Google for about nine and a
half years and I currently am working in
the cloud platform team i run developer
relations as well as our partners and
verticals in mobile space and so i'm
moderating this capacity today as our
director of developer relations and a
lot of our team our developer advocates
or developer program engineers we're
some of the folks that you saw today
actually doing some of the demos and the
team is also responsible for all our
developer documentation the found that
you find on our website as well as our
training the goal of this panel is
really to give you a little bit more of
an inside look of what we're doing with
the Google cloud platform and to hear
from the engineering and product
leadership as well about our vision for
cloud so we're going to open it up for
questions a little bit later there's a
few Mike's so if you do have questions
you can feel free to line up with those
mics when we get there so on our panel
today we have five VPS from engineering
and product who are building Google's
public cloud offering as well as
maintaining our technical infrastructure
that powers all of google so before we
get started with questions I'd love to
kind of go down the list and have each
of you introduce yourselves and share a
little bit with the audience sure I
think I restarted that this morning
Brian Steven so VP responsible for
product management for cloud platforms
and like before this I was at Red Hat
for 12 years running engineering for red
hat and this is an awesome next step to
the journey yoke addict I've been with
school for about 10 years actually when
I joined Google my first touch point was
with gmail so the first touch point with
cloud was scaling gmail from less than a
million users to many many million users
which is really interesting and for last
seven years I that the engineering team
on display ads through the acquisition
of double click and then for the I think
about four months feels much longer but
about four months ago I actually joined
the flower team and responsible now for
developer experience
dan sterman and I'm the VP for
engineering for all our compute products
so that means for you folks things like
Google App Engine Google container
engine announced today and Google
compute engine as well as the underlying
infrastructure at Google that manages
compute across the company I'm Ben
trainer I joined Google 11 years ago to
run this little team called production
and if Google ever stops working it's my
fault it is problem has grown somewhat
since then last 11 years have been very
interesting I've been working on the
cloud team now for about a year and it
also presents some really interesting
challenges in terms of scale and growth
and reliability which I'm applying what
we've learned over the last 11 years to
good effects of our i'm eric brewer I'm
VP infrastructure and I've really been
enjoying working at Google last several
years because of the level of innovation
so my job is really long term
architecture and pushing the engl
pushing out innovation as much as we can
great so thank you for those
introduction so maybe burn we can get
started with you I think one big
question is you were red hat for a long
time you know what brought you to google
um yeah that was a it was a tough
thought process you know I've been an
east coaster for all my whole life so
heavily rooted family and you know and i
think it was um but but that said you
know I've been lucky for many years just
driving ways of disruption from you know
and like I stand earlier it you know
linux and x86 and virtualization and
OpenStack and I think open source
broadly and I think all those are sort
of like disruptors and I've really
redefined you know any part of
technology doesn't really matter whether
it's in mobile or devices or enterprise
or developers and and so really you know
so I think over the past sort of three
or four years I really saw how you know
the public cloud had is really going to
be perhaps if not you know the biggest
thing one of the biggest things ever to
reach IT and so when I got out you know
I want to started talking the google
that you know all the way back in March
I just to be actually be a part of that
instead of just watching that happen
was worth moving for that's great you
know you're you've worked on one of
Google's most successful products which
is ads for many years so where do you
see Google tell you taking me a
developer experience when it comes to
cloud yeah so when that's actually we've
been really fortunate I want to thank
everybody who has worked in the internal
side of Google internal tools and on the
on the Surrey side and production side
so it's been really able to just use all
this and build an enormously complex but
also very scalable system in ads and
seeing all this I'm really excited
actually personally to switch chairs and
and bead instead of being a user of that
infrastructure being somebody who can
provide that infrastructure for
everybody for the external world and I
also think that Google itself is going
to run on this infrastructure as you go
forward so it's a really exciting
process for me to see taking these
assets that we have and delivering the
ease of use and ease of development to
to the whole world so I think as as we
look at where cloud is going we talked
we heard a lot of this morning that
really machines are abundant right
you've seen the data centers to size the
size of the data centers that's not the
shortage you have enough machines we
have enough networking really the
shortages the human resources and all of
you the engineers here who make this
need to make this work both on the
development side and then on the
operations side so think we're really
where we really want to take this is
make that development process a lot
easier and make that deployment process
and operations a lot more efficient so
that you can really focus on on the
evaluated parts and not on the
labor-intensive pieces that you used to
do and so Dan you knew the VP for
compute you know tell us a little bit
about the news today that happened with
the alpha launch of container engine so
container engine really is a start it's
a start of our realized and the vision
we've had for kind
native cloud native built in the cloud
born in the cloud sort of applications
so as you saw during during the
presentations it wasn't standing by
itself it was part of a continuum and
that continuum to yours point was all
about making this the most productive
platform for users so they can kind of
pick and dial in both the level of auto
management and flexibility they need
while at the same time having the
control developers need in order to just
get their jobs done as efficiently and
as well as possible without either being
locked in something don't want to use or
having to worry about issues that just
aren't important to them right now so
that's how I view that that launched and
I think it's like I said this is a start
we're going to be doing more and more in
this space and you know the best way
everyone here can help us just give us
feedback on these alphas these early
releases the faster you give us feedback
the faster we'll get more compelling
more solid product out there it won't be
alpha very long great and so Ben you've
run the SRA organization if not mistaken
from it actually started the time it
started so can you share some
interesting kind of war stories that
have happened coming SRU organization oh
I think I probably have accumulated 20
or 30 good ones right now is maybe I was
already after I'll do what you exactly
i'm holding Grey's up from the after
party I understand um sure sure so what
one of the things is you know Google's
infrastructure is really large at this
point we forget sometimes internally
because we're used to dealing with you
know exabytes and terabits and stuff
like that and it sort of you know you
don't forget that that's not normal but
one of the things that happens is
because it's large things that are
individually very rare right things that
should happen once in a blue moon well
you know across the span of Google they
actually happened kind of every week
somewhere and so we accumulate sort of
these weird tales of things that happen
and we have to deal with the matter
infrastructure one of my personal
favorites occurred actually certainly
after the the you know excellent samuel
l jackson movie snakes on a plane came
out so you know one fine morning in the
carolinas
we had an explosion of one of our high
voltage transformers went offline and ty
bolted transformer is basically that big
yard that did you see where there's
fence around it and they you know claw
air-gap things and you have 150,000
volts coming in and then what we call
medium voltage which is 35,000 volts
going out and so you know we switched
over to one of the other transformers
that we have there because we have
redundancies I've been several stages
down the lines that these things can
happen without our users or our
infrastructure really being affected we
went out the next morning it took a look
and if I what know what happened right
and what we find is more or less
explained by the story that we
reconstructed so a transformer is taking
one voltage and turning into another and
it's not a hundred percent efficient
it's you know maybe ninety nine point
seven percent efficient something like
that but if you're running oh I don't
know 50 megawatts through it even that
point three percent turns into a certain
amount of heat and it's cold right in
the morning and the Carolinas and so a
six-foot-long Carolina black snake had
found its way through the fence and it's
trying to find warmth then eventually it
found the transformer and cuddled up
against it and that was all good but
transformers are basically big winding
coils encased with oil for convective
cooling and so what convective cooling
means that the higher up you go the
warmer it gets as the snake worked its
way up the transformer until it got
within about six feet of the
high-voltage feed at which point the
snake detonated and it detonated hard
enough to blow the insulation the
ceramic insulation off of the end bound
lines on the transformer which causes
them to short which caused the utility
feed to stop so the feed stops power
goes off generators kick on UPS does
exactly those to do so nothing inside
the data center happens accepted ones
like oh my god what happened right and
then you know about ten seconds later
the utility cleared the fault and we
switched over to the redundant
transformer and everything was mine
again but after that I had snakes on a
transformer
we'll try to get back to some of the
more of those stories they said its
keeper so Eric you know you've been a
pioneer in distributed systems so how do
you think the containers are going to
change for companies that maybe just
aren't operating quite a Google scale I
must say I'm highly biased but I love
containers and I love them because they
get you to an abstraction that's much
closer to the way you think when you're
programming which is that you think
about the code you're writing what you
want it to do and not so much about
there's a virtual machine or even
haven't forbidden for that or an actual
machine that you had to deal with that
we're having forbid a transformer I
don't think about transformers good
stories but I don't think about them
right so I kind of feel like once you
get in the mode of dealing with
containers and a higher level of
abstraction you're never going to go
back it's just so clean and and
refreshing in a way to deal with the
stuff you want to think about and when
you have things like the autoscaler you
can just kind of say all i'll start with
three of those you know what I'm wrong
it'll make more right because it's
really easy to cut and paste containers
actually copy and paste containers
cutting case isn't gonna help you any so
you can it'll just make more and then
your load goes down they'll go down
right so I kind of feel like there's the
poles going to be so strong not from the
end users and not from CIOs per se but
from developers write the group that
actually have to create the value this
is what they're going to want to use
right and so I feel like that's why the
whole space is going to move in this
direction and that's I think it's super
exciting ok so i just want to give you
guys a heads up again we're going to
take some questions for the audience
here I'll sort of asked one but I'd like
to open it up to you guys as well so a
lot of the features and announced today
which included cloud interconnect seem
to be targeted at large companies so
when you talk to these companies what do
you hear from them
you know I think that the you know the
first part of i mean i think the cloud
interconnect is one way of sort of
showing our hand that increasingly large
businesses are saying just what Eric's
talking about they're seeing a lot of
the innovation and in large companies
from a cloud approach or being very
untraditional right and so they too are
actually looking at how can they take
advantage of this elastic scale and you
know tremendous amount of assets and
then and then build applications on top
but they haven't been able to do before
just the sheer amount of power but did
but to allow enterprises and large you
know commercial businesses take
advantage of the cloud there's just a
bigger bar right and some of the one of
the bars was actually you know really
getting not just network connectivity to
them but really secure network
connectivity to them and so that was a
big first part of what we talked about
today and there's a whole host of other
things that we're looking at around you
know just you know security arrest all
the way through the network right and
all the way through everything on disk
is has to be security city these are
sort of levels to be honest in the early
days for five years ago we didn't really
have to worry about for developers so
much but when it comes to the enterprise
computing you know it's driving another
whole round and I think it's I think
that's a think it's a good thing I think
too often sort of a bifurcation of its
developer or its enterprise you know
that like somehow that they're separate
and they're they're really not um any
audience questions guys can't be that
shy are you okay I know it's the first
question takes a wild good okay well we
can keep going so we talked a lot about
oh good what do you think it's holding
back the corporates from sort of
embracing this especially given the
return on investment and the promise of
economies of scale and all of that what
do you think is holding back it rolling
up more quickly especially the big ones
well there you know every big one that
you're probably thinking about is
already midway through the conversation
right so i think that traditionally they
just move a little slower right the bars
a little higher right they probably have
you know compliance that they have to
deal with that others don't have to do
with you know data issues privacy issues
all the things that even Google is this
grown-up has to deal with so a lot of it
has been around clearing those hurdles
right some of it was just things that we
had to do or talk about earlier today
just around how we manage billing right
they're not going to credit cards aren't
the way that commercial entities you
know do business its purchase orders so
so I think a lot of a sort of the
maturity of the cloud going forward but
but a lot of that is really sort of the
table stakes really have sort of settled
out and now it's really around the next
stage is really sitting with it's almost
an architectural conversation you know
with the firm's around with our
architects and their architects and
really having a discussion because a lot
of this is new you know to be able to
have auto scaling is not something that
they're used to in their environment to
be able to how they build and develop
applications taking advantage of some of
the you know the bigquery analytics
their re architecting as they come
forward they're not just picking up
applications and coming is that doesn't
really say them anything other than a
little bit of capex and so um so they're
Midway so I don't think it's a I think
it's just you know it's the it's the
it's the big hill that's sort of moving
through and let me just just want to add
one of the other thoughts that which is
it's always be easier to move to
something new when you haven't built
anything yet right so you nothing to
move so I think you know the enterprises
have a huge installed a huge number of
things that were done and things that
gotten used to and you just don't pick
that up you know on a Monday moving on a
Tuesday right so that's something we'll
be looking at how do we make that easier
and so on it and give them tools that
work on permanent off from to help them
with that you know they have the
religion though just like if you sort of
look at sort of what's happening in
Paris right now is this thing called the
OpenStack summit right right and a lot
of them are there as well and I've seen
it firsthand so they have the religion
because all something at the religion
that cloud architecture is the only
architecture that scales you know so
whether there was a public cloud or
themselves managing it as a service
within so they're already there and that
the the you know most of them are
adopting that hybrid strategy right
there trying to build some assets
on-premise and then take advantage of
public cloud but they're they're well
past that should we there into the how
do they and if I may as a follow-up you
with your experience dealing with the
bigger companies do you see it being
more top
or more of a grassroots up or a
combination what works best just out of
curiousity you know and and you know at
that level really just saying that you
know there's always just like any of us
in any of our jobs right we've always
got a list of requirements and things we
want to get to that's a mile long you
know we're just clearing to get there so
to do these large companies and now when
they get through that burn down there
getting to that next project that next
project they're just saying that's going
to be the one we're gonna build it we're
gonna build it here other questions
somebody warmed it up okay um so you
know what's happening next for firebase
we talked a little bit about how
firebase is going to be this key for
mobile tell us more about that yeah i
think the the lowest bar to clear was
probably the one that I that were thread
on twitter is like don't screw them up
but no seriously what we're what we're
trying to do is is with firebases really
give them more resources so they can
execute on what they are already
planning to do and just go faster on it
and also to learn from them in the way
they've they've made it super easy to
get started right so how can we expand
that to a lot of the other assets that
we already have within a boss Google
things like identity things like without
messaging ads and took good analytics so
how can we bring this all together in a
really easy to consume and getting
started on package and I think that's
what you're going to see that's why we
call it the centerpiece right so we're
going to bring that together both for
Android as well as iOS and then also
continue the strong story of support for
various open source and and web to a
kids about no chase and others so that
you can easily develop applications that
on all of the platforms that matter um I
think that's next well I'll add to that
too I snuck up this morning and went by
firebases booth back when they didn't
know who I was
and asking so you know you guys just got
acquired by Google right how does this
change your product or a mapping what
are you going to do differently and they
sort of mold the question over looked at
each other and they're like well doesn't
change anything right we're just now
there's we get to move faster because
wait more resources and there's some
things we don't have to build our self
and I didn't say it but I'm like yes
that's the correct answer another thing
I want to add one other thing which is
that we think who said it I think
correctly michelly said earlier today
that in with some of the solutions
you're kind of forced to color within
the lines right so Google of egg you
know especially if ever plot platform as
a service offering and now that they're
part of of TCP we will certainly have a
much easier path to writing to
extensibility ver you can write
additional logic on the side and tie it
really easily into firebase so that's
another thing that I think will focus on
making that really easy so you know each
of you throughout your careers it seen
quite a bit of evolution and technology
what do you see as some of those
defining moments and if you have any you
know future insight what do you think
those maybe in the future when we first
um you know mine went mine with alpha
lee it's gonna be this one of a mind was
open source right i mean i just think
that you know the source is just like a
paradigm shift that's gonna last an
eternity right because it's just the way
of sort of that IP should be managed and
i just think that this the is that
collaborative nature you know when when
companies and developers align they can
build on the ideas of others i just
think that you know being a part of that
whole movement and actually not leaving
that behind still being a part of that
movement i think is pretty cool and then
the defining moment was like how do you
actually build a business on free
software two billion dollar revenue
business on free software is is also a
pretty crazy aspect but i think that
just goes to show you that it's not
really about the code it's really about
the relationship that a business and the
problem that business can solve you know
to to you know I user base and so I
think that's you know an experience
that's going to lend us out really well
to be in here as well so before I work
for Google at work for IBM and
business was building shrink wrap
software and I think it took me less
than a month after getting to Google
going oh my gosh this software as a
service thing is so much better I'm
never going back you know we have a bug
I don't have to contact all the
customers to figure out what to do about
it we just install a fix right and we
roll forward and I think that's very
telling where we're going to cloud
because a lot of companies are not
moving from on-prem building their own
services in their own installations this
way and you know the service that are
coming to them are also ones that you
know can react very quickly at the speed
of just another push and you'll have to
worry about large install bases that are
kind of inflexible and where you have to
go through another human in order to get
things fixed so for me that was really
come an eye opener and a real change
with it you know technology was at I
think it bodes well for cloud because it
just expands that capability more folks
I already played by hand I think
containers is this kind of step but
going backward I would say the one that
really shifted me personally that it was
a wild ride was really going from
running things on its single machines to
actually running things on clusters and
using that for availability and
scalability is that there was actually
time where that wasn't how it was done
and that shift obviously his is the
foundation of cloud and its really
stayed and it's it's we can't go back
right there's no way back it's the
cluster just get bigger now and so for
each of you or maybe just a couple and
you know what are some of the biggest
challenges that you're dealing with
today sure um so I think for me you know
it's its growth right so I've never seen
a system that's already this large
growing this vast you know even within
Google we have things that are very
large but the growth rates more moderate
this is a little insane you know and to
my pitch each month when I get up in
front of the google employees that's a
okay those of you interest in capacity
planning if something looks like this
right and maybe some months that goes
like that and some once it goes like
that but it's basically like this now we
need to make cane you know n months of
headroom and we need to do this
efficiently so we can keep our prices
going down our costs going down
how are we gonna do this and it's
fascinating i love this kind of
challenge how am I gonna do it how are
we gonna do it um we all want to know
well that you asked me what my biggest
challenges work tell me about your great
victory story I know I mean it you know
edit edit score right so dealing with
with growth is just a a statistical
problem right you know you want to make
sure that people have enough resources
to be able to do what they're planning
to do before they know that they're
doing it and though you can't say that
this customer is going to do X and that
customer is going to do y as a
statistical aggregate you can make
highly accurate predictions about what
they're going to be doing and that lets
us provision resources and say sort of
comfortably ahead of customers usage and
it also lets us do things for them that
they would have real trouble doing for
themselves right if you don't know I
mean at the atomic fiction example this
morning was great right they don't know
that six hours from now that developer
wants to run a 20,000 core rendering job
for 15 minutes and there's no way for
them to figure that out sort of a week
ahead of time but if we have a thousand
customers and each of them does this
sort of thing I can tell you with a
great deal of certainty what the
aggregate load is going to be and what
the variance will be and we can
provision it for them so it's less us do
things for them that's incredibly
valuable that they could not do
themselves and so that's why I think
it's a great challenge to have but it's
still hard others so i think the
managing both the internal Google
infrastructure that we used for compute
which we've had for years and building
the external cloud products you know
we're sitting on a ton of stuff that we
know is cool exciting will really
improve developer productivity but we
got a shift at sideways we got to make
it so it's actually consumable by folks
outside of the company right everything
we built internally was a stack that was
built on the premise everyone's in the
same company and could be used together
so it's a matter of how do we get these
concepts that are kind of known by folks
as they come into the company and make
them consumable and accessible to all
the folks here in a way that makes sense
and if we could just you know somehow
ship the stuff we have internally
outside would make our job a lot easier
so that's something we really have to
work at
so you have an audience hey so
containers are definitely really
interesting in terms of this kind of
middle ground right and I know with a
lot of our clients they love the cloud
they're going there for you know they're
Salters service embracing as you say
like net new development app engine GCE
cloud storage all those things and a lot
of times the question they ask is well
it'd be really great you know I really
believe in this I love the way it works
it scales but there's just sometimes I
really want to run it on my own hardware
do you see the kind of a broader
acceptance as containers across the
industry as being a place where maybe
there's a middle ground for those type
of organizations who really they
understand the scalability of the cloud
for like ninety-nine percent of their
workload but there's that one percent
where they need to be able to have the
flexibility to move back and forth
especially for folks with you know data
sensitivity global organizations
actually several things that came out
today make that story easier but for
sure one of the Vantage's containers as
you saw in the demo this morning is you
can let it on your laptop you can write
in the cloud you can run on Prem it's
the same container with the same
contents and when use coover Nettie's
with that you get the same cluster of
containers you can move the whole
cluster right so that what we showed
today was in some sense new for the
first time you move a cluster from not
in the cloud into the cloud right and if
you use the cloud connect you can do to
repay n securely from on-prem to cloud
so these are these are the kinds of
features that enable exactly the
scenarios you just mentioned and those
are real scenarios for lots of reasons
fact another one that came out 2day
little subtly is that you can run your
goober Nettie's cluster in a wide
variety of regions so if you have
jurisdictional issues you want your data
in a certain place that'll run there and
now that was going to be one of my
questions was I know traditionally you
know look at App Engine and compute
engine there's these broad geographic
categories is the roadmap for containers
and really all the services going to
come more granular because oftentimes we
have clients who are like we would
gladly stand up 10 extra instances each
and you know one of these countries if
we knew the data would be there as you
say you have you know data centers all
over the world that seems kind of like a
no-brainer right yet you're everywhere
so I can't we do this is that something
that is being thrown around considered I
don't know what we're ready to announce
but absolutely yeah you can guess that's
the direction we're going I think it
would be fair to say that that many
customers have made exactly this
observation to us and were not in the
habit of ignoring what people are trying
to do how's that for a very guy did not
answer haha I'll take it thank you okay
um so you know I formerly was a CIO at
Motorola and I was really concerned
about privacy and security and data
management so what do you say to CIOs
today and we'll also have similar
concerns I think security is a is a
really hard problem right so there's so
much so much that can be attacked and
that you have to look after so going
into the cloud actually kind of helps
you offload a lot of those security
issues to the cloud provider and it's
very few companies that we heard that to
this morning in the in the video that
fortunate enough to be able to attract a
team of hundreds of security engineers
sort of world class and actually enjoy
poking holes into other people's
software including our our own and many
of them actually have been able to
discover like first day vulnerabilities
and publish them and we heard about the
ssl back that was one of our google
engineers to discover that so i think
going forward security is actually one
of the drivers from my perspective that
will drive people to use the cloud more
because they feel that on premise is
hard for them to replicate that level of
sophistication of intrusion detection
and honey pots and and a team that is is
really looking after the whole whole
stack that's a good point i mean i think
that too often we thought the inside
drone firewall met security right I
think we've sort of seen the lessons I
don't know if you have to replace my
credit cards twice this year already you
know that it that's just not true so I
think it's not really around where your
data is it do you have a partner that's
thinking security all day long I guess I
dad there's no substitute for being
attacked for ten years right most of the
things that you learn security you learn
the hard way and if you haven't had ten
years through that which ben has had and
others i think there's no substitute for
that so that's how you get to be a
secure place is being attacked and
driving through that and to be clear
right this job never ends I think we're
not boosting about being being the most
secure place on earth but we certainly
feel that we're doing a lot to make sure
that your data is safe with us so back
in March at gcp live or is actually
suggested in five years we would look
back on 2014 and be embarrassed right
about how we're building and writing
software today so looking forward where
do you see the cloud industry headed and
what might we see in 2019 that will make
us look back and laugh at 2014 so you
know I think the key difference you're
going to see is that it takes a lot for
your people in order to do something
really cool and exciting you know
ideally where we think things are going
where we're trying to drive is you know
one biz dev got one biz guy three
developers can do a really exciting
business and scale it right all the way
up now we're not there yet by any means
cloud has already shown some of the
sorts of improvements but the realities
right now you still have issues with
growing pains and more and more
maintenance as you get bigger to work
out so that's what I think is gonna be
exciting we're going to look back as the
differences and I think with that will
come a huge burst in productivity and
ingenuity and
in addition just because he will be
freed up to do that i would add i mean
so you know watching some of the demos
today right one of the things i always
find compelling is is you know how
difficult is the null project or the
hello world project to actually
implement in a system and obviously we
saw the folks from firebase give a great
example of what at the hello world in
you know it's true did mobile app looks
like and that's you know that's very
compelling i just developer i look at
that it's like okay cool i could build
something the other thing that i've seen
over the last eleven years has been that
every service as its scales runs into
the same kinds of problems right you
have load balancing issues you have
cascade failure issues you have
distributed denial-of-service attack
issues you have provisioning questions
and so on and so forth and you know i
think part of her clearly is to make it
as you say that that you know three
developers and and you know zero people
working on operations can get something
off the ground my goal is actually that
they can also get it to a million QPS
without needing to hire anybody because
they're gonna have a hat you know have
to handle the same kind of problems over
and over again and our cloud support
will give it to them right because we've
already dealt with this right when we've
spent 15 years doing was not a million
gps running globally in you know 12
different jurisdictions and so on and
not having to think about those issues
or what that involves if you're at a
million QPS you're already pretty much
everywhere from a sure yeah that or
you're just adding to this what I've
seen just to study recently that really
there's actually correlation of the
success of a start-up with how many
tools they use positive correlation so
it's just shows that if you use the
right tools you can actually go a lot
faster goes back to the point that
you're making so I think we will invest
into giving you access to your pop to
the tools that you like and also we're
going to develop some of our own that
will make your life a lot easier and I
think I'm looking back if you look back
in five years back to the way software
was developed today you'll probably say
that was relatively primitive yeah and I
think that you know just sort of
harkening back to sort of the whole open
source thing is that nobody going to go
out and usually write a new web server
anymore you know or you're going to
build on something that's probably
already out there and i think that the
same things true so from a run time
perspective you're still doing far too
you're doing a lot more than just
writing your business logic for your app
today right you still you're still even
even what we showed you we think is
pretty compelling but you're still
picking sizes of clusters number of
cores right amount of memory do you want
an SSD do not want an SSD so we're still
making you even in the most advanced
cloud I think making you pick
architectural choices which is kind of
crazy right so ultimately ating from the
oars question we want to be asking those
questions five years down the road
you'll be throw an application logic at
the cloud will be dealing with the
availability of it scalability
resilience if it needs more performance
we're going to detect that we're going
to tech by that's IO or memory you know
what's throttling it we're going to
expand that horizontally vertically
whatever it takes right and so that to
me is the ultimate in the service right
and you're still only being able to use
but you can you don't have to be in
there like sizing and monitoring and
you're still selling monitoring because
you're monitoring it right in the
reality of just the fact that you're
monitoring your app which is kind of
where the state of the art is today then
probably as a service or something that
we're not delivering on so I think
that's sort of the stretch of five years
from now is that you're just throwing
business logic at the cloud and there's
a couple of steps in between right where
we can not where we can take let's say
your money I'm the product manager guy
say like you do that instead so for
example the monitoring is a very good
example where we can probably detect a
lot of things where you don't actually
have you don't have the Lord set on this
right we just detect something is
different today than it was yesterday
which is allergy and tell you that you
should call me out here on yeah exactly
right which I mean and which is also
nice right because if you use things
like confidence interval monitoring what
it means that as your app grows and the
users the usage of the app changes you
don't have to constantly rewrite your
monitoring so that it's detects what the
new failure modes are right because
failure modes in general are you know
strong deviation from the norm and yeah
you know we use this internally there's
no reason you guys shouldn't also
benefit from it with this modern the
most modern cloud platform the dimension
and the tagline that caught my attention
was the data center is computer so we
tap trend what are some of the dream
applications that you think of as a
consumer
or somebody built that will do real
justice to this new architecture I think
you saw two today you saw atomic fiction
which is pretty amazing they're totally
hiding the fact that there's a giant
computer under there right in fact the
size of that computer changes
dynamically as well and then you saw
bigquery which although it's not new is
an incredibly powerful thing issue a
small query that anyone can type and it
can use a huge number of cores and
across a huge amount of data to do
something that it's really i think in a
league by itself all right so it's
absolutely a thing that is a whole data
center query yeah the reason I ask this
is to get into that paradigm as a
developer what are those reference
applications today or five years from
now that way we is accompanying our part
of building that those kind of
applications are there many today other
than these couple of examples or any
dream you wish you know we're creating
this amazing architecture I wish
somebody built that I kind of say when
the way we think about it is that we've
built many of these that's what search
is that's what ads is what gmail is that
does Google and I'm I understand but ok
so I now think we have we know how to
build them we don't know how to do yet I
would say is to make it easy for
everyone to build them but that's where
we're going but I think there's some
patterns that might many go to go so for
example I think things like you know
data analysis will go to really of how
much am I willing to spend to get the
answer not a thinking about how many
machines do I have and therefore how
long does it take from you get this done
right it'll be really just what's my
dollar limit and you can add more
dollars and get a better answer that's
usually how this data analysis works or
spend fewer dollars and getting that
paradigm where it's kind of infinitely
scalable in the right way you write your
app and I think you'll see that was like
data flow and so on building apps that
work that way I think you'll also be
even put effect you'll see the same also
with both in data systems and serving
systems that you're not thinking about
how many users or how many QP
am i building for that again is since
you're building a pen is what we do
inside Google you're building for a
paradigm of you know again for dollar
cost I can handle this much had this
many QPS was against the back and system
or front end system and it's just a
development paradigm where you're
thinking about just I have infinite
resource and what's constraining me is
my budget how much is this budget this
business worth to me and that's a
paradin that translates into a style of
coding eventually which I think
containers have to set us up for but
will be patterns with that around you
know how do you store persistent data
what sort of backends use for persistent
data how do you store front end
information and so on so I think it's
less about what are the apps because I
think almost every app the apps that are
changing our lives daily around mobile
and the Internet can kind of be built
this way but it's going to be a set of
developer patterns and paradigms that
start to avoid you're doing things like
putting well here's a single point of
failure in an application that help you
design around that and we'll be helping
bring that forward so I was spotting so
you may notice we're struggling slightly
with your question here's the reason
we're struggling with your question I
think I put my finger on it right so
we've actually been doing this data
center as a computer right don't worry
about individual servers thing for more
than a decade at Google if we had dream
applications that needed that paradigm
we would already have written them right
so you're asking us what apps have you
guys not yet thought of please tell me
and and the answer is we can't known in
the book but what we're doing actually
is much more important I think right
we're trying to allow everyone like you
to dream up the new apps and be able to
write them without having to build all
the infrastructure that is required to
make a data center into a computer right
and so our hope my hope certainly is
that in five years from now right when
we think about what it means to program
a computer what we're actually thinking
about what it means to program a data
center because this idea of programming
a single computer is sort of as quaint
as the idea of writing microcode is now
so I'm hoping you will show us with the
dream app is thank you
so there's been a lot of discussion
today about using toolchain to observe
anomalous behavior that's been made
operational leave done a deployment
you're seeing an almost behavior can
attack it and there's been a lot of
discussion about advancing the thought
of business and how many software
developers it takes to play a solution
and how much more capable they are the
one thing I don't know that we've talked
about quite as much and I'd be very
interested in your thoughts is what does
the future of software quality look like
because there is still this problem of
business person has an idea software
developer turns that into working code
it gets deployed I don't know that I
want my customers to be the people that
tell me it's not working even if those
tools are highly advanced so how do we
move software quality along at a similar
pace Thanks absolutely so I mean one of
the things I would say is this goes back
to what Dan said earlier it's like this
this notion of actually being able to
deliver software right from from the top
of the repository and and really having
a daily release completely changes the
way you develop a software and I think
with that goes said you have to stage
things in some way or the other right so
there's many different ways of staging
and then obviously also testing these
things so whether you start testing
things on every commit or having
continuous integration tests that are
running as a service part of your normal
development cycle I think those are some
of the the usual techniques but also if
you look and I think it's become like I
was shocked really I've came from a from
a background of first shrink wrap
software to us of developing on open
office where you had releases that were
roughly every six months by then you
come to Google and in Gmail you release
pretty much like every day right you'd
release just what's been committed an
hour ago and it gets released but
obviously that doesn't mean that this
what what was developed an hour ago
actually hits the user it's usually
behind a flag items a feature that you
turn on when you've proven it and you
turn it on for a couple of users and you
test it out and then you turn it on
more and and so on and you probably have
a stage in cluster you don't push it to
all machines at once there's a lot of
things that you can do in this software
development process that allows you to
get feedback I think one of the things I
personally learned over the years is you
really cannot guarantee that there's no
back in your code right you have to find
it very fast and you have to limit the
exposure to customers for this from this
buck so if you can find it early with
the regression testing that's ideal if
you can find it with the internal users
that's okay if you find a bit out of our
users okay not so great but you just
have it definitely shouldn't exposed to
all of you users to the back at the same
time and those are so much techniques do
you want to add something i'll add
something so i think also since you know
you're dealing with a cloud environment
dealing with them since a virtualized
environment as these environments get
richer with some of the things you've
seen today but stuff will be coming out
the future from very cloud providers
it's easier to say well it's virtualized
while I make two copies right so it
makes setting up a rich test environment
much easier and with that thing comes
the power that it's very easy to throw a
lot of resources very quickly in order
to ensure software quality where does
this break where does this release break
for compared to the prior release and
again going back to the same board
before this turns it now into a budget
issue right that just how much is
software quality work to me let me put a
number on that I can really pound the
heck out of everyone every new developer
does you know up to that budget limit
and give you that level of quality and
on top of that since this is not
production software this is your tests I
think you're going to see providers like
ourselves and others make this very very
affordable for folks so the amount you
can get for your dollar in terms of
software quality will be quite a bit
right so so I think going back to what
we're saying before today about you know
this technology shouldn't just be used
the way the old technology to think
you'll see this will be a particularly
good place where because we're on the
cloud we can think fundamentally
differently about software quality and
how we exercise that quality and how we
understand how does release you know two
dot one different release to dot oh and
bring a lot of tools to play on that to
again take that labor away from
individual developers and testers and
ops people and maybe just one other
thing is that
thing especially on mobile devices we've
acquired a purifier because we really
think this is a great great service and
something that all of you should
probably look into is testing your of
your applications on many many many
different devices before you release
them right so this I think the cloud is
a perfect place for that where we can
visualize these things and make them
available to lots of different
developers so you don't have to buy
thousands of devices in every like every
startup doesn't have to buy a thousand
devices you can just use them as you
need them great any other audience
questions ok um so sort of the last
question um not to be forward-looking
but we keep seeing pricing cuts what is
their bottom are we going to continue to
see this I see no bottom is this time it
you know I think there's there's two
major things obvious that drive this one
is that the underlying hardware keeps
getting less expensive right we're
making we not we but the industry is
making continued R&D improvements right
a you know a Giga flop is getting
cheaper over time to deliver and that
means that the infrastructure that we
purchased to provide services gets
cheaper and that means that the price
goes down and secondly were as we learn
more about how the rest of the world
runs services in cloud we're finding
more and more ways to make it efficient
to provide you know VMs with performance
characteristics that they're looking for
at less of a cost in underlying
infrastructures of course as we do that
then that decreases art awesome we can
also pass some of those along and yeah I
mean you know I've heard people say oh
no surely you can't keep cutting prices
well if you've looked at what's happened
to networking costs over the last ten
years they've come down a lot and
they're continuing to come down in fact
we sort of track it every year because
we have this you know demand and we have
this cost curve on the revenue and I
don't see the cost curve
down and then stopping anytime in the
foreseeable future yeah i think the ben
was right on the nose I mean what's
what's driving this is not our
imagination that we should cut costs the
underlying cost computing as it has you
know since the 60s keeps decreasing
right of what it costs to get a
particular unit right so as long as
that's happening I think we should see
and expect cloud to keep theirs and
paying that the pricing today hasn't all
been a reaction to the market to be
honest right it's really been just a
statement of philosophy of sort of how
we think that we should be pricing and I
think we have as many conversations not
just on a feature to bring out but you
know an algorithm that's going to
improve efficiency is just as important
as a new feature and so that's how we
think about it and so when you see you I
always loved the the weird non-round
numbers that we showed this morning
right 2347 I mean those are really
directly correlated with the efficiency
improvement right not a market reaction
that this should be fifty percent off
this should be ten percent off and so
there's as many new ideas that I think
we've seen the office just in the past
couple of weeks on some cool things
where there's additional overhead that
can make this thing even better it's the
hazards of working with an engineering
driven companies get the odd numbers
from things great well I really want to
thank the panel for joining today and I
actually want to thank all of you for
joining us we hope that you found this
to be a really great day we really
enjoyed having you both in person and
for those of you that are watching
online thank you very much